Europe is trying to soften the economic
blow dealt by the coronavirus EU leaders
have signed off on an emergency rescue
package to help countries deal with the
immediate fallout of the crisis they
also agreed to set up a fund to secure
the blocks long term recovery but they
are still divided on how this would be
financed while thea northern countries
are refusing to pool debts as requested
by some southern countries but germany
has agreed to increase the amount it
pays into the EU budget more on that in
a moment but first this report the video
conference was the fourth such meeting
since the virus hit EU countries and
expectations were low human burst states
have so far failed to agree on how to
help those economies hit hardest by the
pandemic but after just a few hours the
council president emerged emphasizing
the country's common interests this
pandemic is putting our societies and
serious strain the well-being of each
human the state depends on the
well-being of the whole of the EU we are
all in this together Michelle said
leaders had agreed to task the EU
Commission with linking a recovery plan
to the AU's next long-term budget
au Commission president was a laFonda
line called for unity unless we acted
decisively and collectively the recovery
will not be symmetric and divergences
between member states will increase
speaking to press in Berlin after the
meeting German Chancellor Angela Merkel
also stressed what this meant for
Europe's biggest economy for Germany it
means we have to expect higher
contributions for the --use next budget
it's clear we need some kind of
financial instrument or recovery plan or
recovery fund and I want to be very
clear here a collective response is also
in Germany's interest
Berlin has expressed a willingness in
recent days to offer more aid to other
struggling EU economies and eurozone
finance ministers had already agreed on
the principle of an EU recovery fund the
big problem the size and nature of this
new debt instrument has yet to be
decided
but after Thursday's meeting Italian
Prime Minister Giuseppe contr hailed the
progress being made the most important
thing is that this urgent and necessary
instrument has been confirmed Italy led
the calls for our initiative and the
letter signed by eight other countries
was very important an instrument like
this was absolutely unthinkable until
now despite the praise detailed on the
plan a sparse and many suspect the EU
commission's toughest negotiations are
yet to come and I'm now joined by DWS
chief political correspondent Melinda
Crain hello Melinda so Germany will pay
the biggest share of the emergency fund
that EU leaders have agreed to set up is
there bound to be some opposition to
that here in the country there will
certainly be opposition from the
far-right alternative for Germany party
the AFD they said very clearly yesterday
that they were not willing to see any
kind of increased aid from Germany to
help other EU members particularly the
hard-hit southern European countries but
otherwise the mild so far criticism or
somewhat mild criticism of what we've
been hearing is coming from different
members of the political spectrum
including the junior coalition partner
the Social Democrats saying the
agreement yesterday didn't go far enough
and Germany's commitment didn't go far
enough that bolder action is needed to
really get an effective recovery fund up
and working so are the so-called corona
bonds that countries like Germany and
other northern countries are opposed to
are they now off the table no so far
basically nothing is off the table the
Chancellor said very clearly yesterday
both in her remarks to the German
Bundestag and also in her
forints after that EU video summit that
Germany was ruling such mutualization of
debt out but the fact is that what the
summiteers yesterday decided in their
video conference essentially was to hand
the whole subject back to the EU
Commission the Commission is supposed to
come up with an exact assessment of how
bad the damage is in different sectors
in different countries across the EU and
then make recommendations about how this
fund could be set up and how its payout
would look and so at the moment there's
bound to be a debt the Commission will
have to borrow money in order to fund
any kind of fund of this proportion but
the question is what that might look
like Germany has made its position clear
so have other northern European
countries right Malinda just just
briefly another thing Michel did say
yesterday was that Germany's well being
dependent on Europe being well what what
does she mean by that well Germany is an
export world-class exporter as we know
and two-thirds of its exports go to
other EU member countries and two-thirds
come from other EU member countries in
other words even if the German economy
emerges from this crisis quickly and it
has in fact put into place some of the
biggest rescue packages anywhere in the
world without recovery in the rest of
the EU Germany's economy cannot flourish
that was her message and that message
it's absolutely accurate and even a
two-track EU where some countries are
languishing while others flourish that
will not work out well for this very
very open German economy in future
all right that's DW is Melinda crane
thank you now staying here in Germany
the munich-based IFO Institute for
economic research has just released its
latest business climate survey results
it shows German business confidence
plummeted to a record low in April as
firms fret over the coronavirus falleth
now we've invited the President of the
IFO Institute to talk more on that
Clemens first joins me from Munich
welcome to DW mr. for so German business
has never
Ben this pessimistic about the future
what does that mean materially it means
that they will reconsider their plans
they will certainly invest less they may
dismiss people they make up the labor
force the survey also tells us that
their current business situation is very
bad so that means the money that is
coming in the sales they still have are
very low and that means they are
accumulating losses and that of course
reinforces the trend to cut back
spending to cut back capex so the crisis
is getting deeper here okay has there
been support for business and and what
do you make of the the rescue package
that EU leaders have now agreed to well
there has been a lot of support
mobilized mainly by the German
government and in other EU countries by
the respective national governments what
the U rescue package is doing now is
basically two things first of all the U
is trying to prevent a return of the
debt crisis investors are nervous about
some countries in the euro zone Italy
for instance and they need a signal from
the EU that there will be no liquidity
problems for the Italian government the
second issue is that we need to organize
reconstruction recovery after this
crisis is over and there is now a fun
being set up for that these are good
signs but they cannot prevent the fact
that we are now in this crisis that we
now have this shutdown and we need to
deal with that right so the million
dollar question here well the global
economic recovery from the pending make
me be quick and strong or will it be
slow what do you think it's very
unlikely that it will be quick we know
that there will be hardly a vaccine this
year probably not even in 2021 so that
means we will live with the restrictions
we now have the world economy will stay
on at a lower level for some time so the
recovery will be slow
and will disappoint those who hope for a
v-shaped recovery its I don't think it's
going to happen
okay that's Clements first from the IFO
Institute for Economic Research talking
to us from unique thank you Thank You
Christine and here's a look at some of
the latest developments in the corona
virus pandemic the global death toll
from covert 19 has surpassed 190,000
according to Johns Hopkins University
the number of confirmed cases is
approaching 3 million China has reported
no new coronavirus deaths for the ninth
straight day and just six new cases two
of those were brought from overseas with
four domestic cases Indonesia will
temporarily ban domestic and
international air and sea travel
starting this week it's already bad
movement from cities to the provinces
during the Ramadan holiday period and
hungry plans to replace its lockdown
which included a blanket curfew on the
entire population with more targeted
measures from early May the new rules
are to focus on those at high risk u.s.
President Donald Trump has been
criticized by medical experts for
suggesting that injections of
disinfectant or the use of ultraviolet
light might help to cure coronavirus
patients mr. Trump made the comment
softer an official outlined research on
the effects of sunlight and household
disinfectants on the virus outside to
the body
a Portuguese migrant center has been
evacuated after the vast majority of the
175 residents tested positive for the
new corona virus authorities ordered
mass testing of all residents of the
Lisbon facility after one of them was
found to be carrying the virus several
beaches in Australia's largest city
Sydney have been closed again after
crowds ignored coronavirus restrictions
locals or other local officials had
reopened the beaches for exercise just a
few days earlier while at the same time
warning people to adhere to social
distancing guidelines critics of
lockdown say some governments are using
them to curtail civil liberties and in
some case
violate Human Rights as part of an
ongoing series here at DW our
correspondents around the world look at
the situation in the countries that they
are covering with turkey having now on
the world's highest infection rates for
kovat 19 people are increasingly turning
to the last few remaining independent
newspaper outlets for news but President
earth one has declared war not only on
the epidemic but also on what he called
media and political viruses new
legislation has been introduced from
reporting on the epidemic which is even
saw a local newspaper editor from a
nearby city dragged from his home in the
middle of the night despite such
pressures critical journalism is
continuing even though it runs a risk of
a knock on the door from the police
security agencies in Nigeria have been
accused of human rights violations
against citizens while enforcing the
lockdown
according to Nigeria's National Human
Rights Commission also 18 people have
been killed by security agencies that's
almost the same number of deaths caused
by coronavirus itself here in Beijing
life feels quite normal and at the same
time it feels like you're stuck in a big
fortress normally because you can go on
about your daily life you can go to a
barber shop and cut your hair go to a
restaurant you can go shopping this all
comes with restrictions and for example
when I enter a supermarket there's
always a camera that scans my body
temperature and also I have to show us a
QR code from my smartphone to prove that
I'm healthy the big restriction however
comes when you leave Beijing because
once you return you have to parent in
for 14 days no matter what however the
Chinese are really disciplined when it
comes to complying with the restrictions
and I really respect them for them